okay I think we can proceed with a nice
finger java class besitos HD University
member working on micro magnetism around
right and now is a technical university
in Vienna and yeah for what to a like
yeah especially perspective on a date a
scientific problem now let's work on
class thank you very much for the kind
introduction and thank you for the
opportunity to speak here and yeah topic
of my talk will be scientific computing
with Python and I'm mostly dealing with
continuous problems so i have to say
that I'm not like you guys a creator of
the Python language as that like that
but just a simple user so the whole talk
will be from the perspective of a
scientific Python user and the Python
stuff will be pretty basic I guess so
let's come to the outline of my talk I
will start and give an introduction to
magnetism and how this is connected to
partial differential equations because
that's kind of my research topic in
Vienna and then I pick out two methods
for the solution of partial differential
equation one would be define a
difference method and i will show how to
like apply this method with python and
what problem arises what province arises
and in the last part i will give a short
introduction into finite elements and
some tools we are using to solve partial
differential equations with finite
elements and finally I will conclude so
a bit about me and as Philip mentioned I
got my PhD in Hamburg and since one year
now i live in vienna and still working
on micro magnetism that means we are
developing simulation software for
magnetic nanostructure
isn't spintronic devices and in
particular i'm interested in numerical
algorithms for the solution of partial
differential equations and here my work
is partly funded by a company infineon
and as part of this collaboration we are
developing and trying to improve
magnetic sensors especially further for
automotive applications them so let's
start with a brief introduction into
ferromagnetism as you might know from
school ferromagnet is consists of a
large number of elementary magnets and
you can think of these elementary
magnets as Tiny compass needles so these
are dipoles and all these elementary
magnets interact with each other through
different mechanisms and ya on the next
slide we will have a look at these
different contributions which make the
magnetization move in time so the the
most simple contribution is the
so-called seamen energy so every
magnetic depot lights likes to be
aligned in parallel to an external field
they're supposed to be a large arrow so
the external field points in this
direction and the elementary magnet
likes to stay aligned parallel
antiparallel would be very bad for the
energy so the next contribution is
called the magnetization field so as I
told you every elementary magnet is kind
of a small magnetic people and that
means it not only moves in magnetic
fields but it also create magnetic
fields in this case the dipole field
this is yeah okay you can see they're
here varies slide magnetic field lines
and yes in these fields generated by
this magnetic dipole every other
elementary magnet tries to align in
parallel again so that means the field
line goes like this so if I put another
elementary magnet here
still I'm antiparallel and so this
coupling is bidirectional that means
this magnet also creates a field and
this act in the view created by the
right elementary magnet and if you now
put in more and more magnets sorry if
you put in more and more magnets you
will see that configurations are
energetically favored that have closed
flux lines and that's why this
contribution is also called the
magnetization field because it tries to
demagnetize the whole magnetic body so
if there was only this interaction we
wouldn't have microscopic magnets this
is where the exchange interaction comes
into play and the exchange interaction
is a quantum mechanical effect which
prefers neighboring elementary magnets
and that means elementary magnets bose
wave functions overlap and these
neighboring magnets are have a lower
exchange energy if they align in
parallel so this is a very local field
and now the interesting part in
magnetism is that we have this
competition between the global
demagnetization fuge which tries to
demagnetize the whole body and a very
strong local view the exchange for you
which tries to get a homogeneous
magnetization configuration so it's kind
of a multiscale problem if we want to
simulate large structures we not only
have to like take into account the
global interactions but we also have to
look very closely in detail how this
short-range interactions take place so
how do we compute such a structure and
if we look at the at the body of say
size in the micrometer-sized we it
consists of like 10 to the power of 23
elementary magnets so this is obviously
not a number we can handle with a
computer
em so what we do instead is and we make
a model which is continuous that means
we start with a discrete model go to a
continuous space and now we try to solve
the problem in this continuous base but
until now we started like with with 10
to the power of 23 degrees of freedom
and now we are in the continuous space
that means we have infinitely many
degrees of freedom so what do we do we
still can't computed and so we have
again to discretize the space and we do
this by them creating a mesh and this
mesh can either be a simple regular grid
like this one or can look like this and
depending on the method we are using we
are able to handle more complex or more
simple measures so what did we gain by
going from the discrete to the
continuous back to the disk read first
thing we gain is that usually the
discretization we need in order to
compute this model can be much larger
than the resolution of the elementary
magnet m so we have less degrees of
freedom and on the other hand them our
model now is described by partial
differential equations and there there
is a very well very good American
framework to sort of such kind of
problems so we can rely of many
mathematical methods and so on ok this
is a real bird example which we are able
to simulate with our software it's a
right head of a magnetic hard drive and
it consists basically of three parts the
first one is an electric coil so the
current flows through this coil and
creates an electric field and the second
part is this one this is the magnetic
material where we want to write our
abides and then there is this yoke and
this
magnetic yoke like guides the magnetic
flux to the poly tip which you can see
here and this pole tip is very small in
order to create very local fields in
order to write small bites and the whole
writing process looks like this so the
current in the coil is switched in
direction and as you can see a
magnetization flux goes through the yoke
and is able to right by it ok so how how
do the problems we have to solve look
like this is a brief overview over the
micromagnetic model as you can see there
are many couple of differential
equations and it looks kind of scary and
complicated and in order to show you how
to solve these problems with Python I
decided to focus on a more simple
problem and this is kind of the mother
of all a partial differential equations
and it's called Poisson equation this is
the laplace operator this is the
solution we are looking for and this is
some right hand side and I would try to
I will like try to do as less math as
possible but I thought as kind of
motivation because that's the part I'm
coming from it's may be good to have
some equation and yeah in the following
there will be less formula M so as I
told you in the beginning essentially i
will show you two different methods to
solve such vs system one of which is the
final difference method and in fine a
difference method we always have to act
on these regular grids and as you can
see this is not so good if we want to
describe curved structures like the
circle so we get artifacts on the edges
but a big advantage of this method is
that we have a couple of very fast
algorithms so if we have simple
geometries it's always better to go with
this method if we have curvature and
complicated structures we use the finite
element method and as you can see in
this method we can use irregular grid
and yeah one of the big advantages as
you can see is that we can model the
curvature pretty pretty good even with
relatively large simulation cells okay
let's start with the finite difference
method the solution we are looking for
is a continuous solution but as I told
you we have to do some discretization
somewhere so how do we do that let's
look at some continuous function you and
try to discretize it and if we have a
regular grid and if we consider one
dimensional example the discretization
is straightforward so we have a regular
grid and we start with a continuous
function which has a value at any point
X and we transform it into a vector
which has an indice I and so UI is just
defined by the value of the continuous
function you at the point X I and X is
chosen to be equidistant and so this is
how we get some continuous functions
into the computer and the next question
is we want to solve differential
equations that means we somehow have to
discretize our differential operator and
in this case is the laplace operator and
in n dimensions the laplace operator is
given by the sum of the second
derivative in the different spatial
dimensions now we are in one dimension
so the laplace operator simplifies to
just the second as spatial derivative
and what we do now in finite differences
is that as you might know the derivative
is defined by like infinitely small
differences and what we now do is we
don't take infinitely small differences
in order to get like the slope of our
function but we just approximated by
finite differences and that means we can
approximate the second derivative at the
node I by taking the values of
neighboring cells with some weight so
this is has a weight plus 1 obviously
this has a way
minus 2 obviously and this is plus 1 and
then we divide by our spatial
discretization constant H so H is did
exactly the width of one interval here
and this is a very simple approximation
of the second derivative and so with
this tool we have everything we need in
order to compute the solution to a
Laplace a personal equation in one
dimension so what features does our
programming language has to have in
order to solve such a problem
efficiently we want to be able to deal
with very large data sets maybe not that
large as your data sets but at least we
want to be able to alight describe
systems with say millions of nodes and
we want to be fast because we are
interested in the time evolution of the
system we want to be able to like
simulate the system not only for split
seconds but for a longer time ranges so
we just need speed most of the
operations we need our kind of single
instruction multiple data so the
language should be able to handle these
kinds of problems well and it would be
nice if we also get some hard ization
where possible and what we don't need
and is redundancy or fire safety because
if there's simulation fails we just
started again and we don't need real
time there is no data coming in we have
to store and we have to keep forever or
whatever so we we are just interested in
if we have start configuration of the
magnetization and we define some
external fields or so that we are
interested in what happens and if the
simulation fails or takes too long we
just do it again or just wait another
month for the results and okay so why
why did we choose Python for these
computations python python has a concise
syntax and usually python code is very
readable and
in this context python is very well
suited for building kind of
domain-specific languages so we can like
create an API for our physical problems
that reads a bit like the problem itself
so this is a nice thing to have you if
you collaborate with other physics
students or so that they really can
capture what the code is that what the
what the code is doing and another big
plus of python is that we have ipython
so for prototyping and for trying out
new libraries we have an interactive
thing where where we can fast try out
and stuff em then this is a bit
controversial python is dynamically
typed this is one of the reasons why the
syntax is so brief on the other hand
there sometimes problems so I personally
like these dynamically typed languages
because of the brief syntax others don't
and and the last and most important part
for us is it fast and as it's
dynamically typed and as its interpreted
language and we probably might run into
performance issues for some tasks so I
put the speed on the minus part here but
with a question mark M so let's have a
look at how Python yeah performs
compared to see and we start with a
simple loop as I told you most of the
operations we do is a single instruction
multiple data so this is kind of the
most simple instruction we can do we
just start with a vector with 1 million
entries and we want to multiply each
entry with two and we do this 10 times
and in Python the for loop looks like
this so we loop over the range of the
length of the index and then we multiply
each entry by 2 and the exact same thing
and see here we haven't I have an outer
look I died I do the thing 10 times so
that the time measurement is
meaningful and it's not too fast then so
almost the same code let's look at the
execution time Oh python is pretty slow
so obviously if we perform this
operation by using four loops in Python
we get a performance yeah we get it 70
times where is performance then and see
you so what do we do we do about this m
we just use a library which is able to
handle these kinds of problems and yeah
you're all will know the num pi library
and I got some bullet prams points from
the home page so they claim that nampa
has a powerful n dimensional array
object tools for integrating c and
fortran code and linear linear algebra
fourier transform random number
capabilities so that sounds like
something we can use to solve such kind
of problems and specifically the first
point might be important for the thing
we want to do and now we mmm that's too
bad now we do the same thing as before
but using an umpire to multiply each
element with two and and if we have a
numpy m array we can just perform the
same simulation without a for loop by
just applying the multiplication
directly on the object and numpy does
the iteration over the objects m and
this is supposed to be much faster and
if we look at the execution time m
we can see that indeed the numpy
performance now is close to the sea
performance but it's exactly the same
actually am so the first rule obviously
is avoid four loops in Python if you if
you want to do computational physics and
try to use some collective operations on
the numpy arrays here's some more
information on how we use numpy so if we
want to compute the finite difference
for a one-dimensional array them so
let's try to translate this expression
to numpy then we can use the slicing
capabilities I don't know it kick can
you read this or is it too okay but
maybe if you are familiar with the
slicing then we can compute this for
every element by just copying the Aerie
three times and like shifting it with
the slicing operations multiply this one
by two and then add the array and then
we get the computation of the second
derivative for all elements at once and
this is not only fast but this is also
very elegant because this really looks
like the expression we are trying to
code here so then the next thing until
now we just moved in one dimension but
we want to move to a three-dimensional
structures sooner or later so it's very
nice to have these n dimensional arrays
and yeah you can create them like this
and you can access them and you can also
slice each dimension individually and
every operation that numpy supports has
an axis argument so you can sum up only
one X's or doing an fft and only one X's
or in all access at once and so on so
this is very nice you can do plenty of
stuff on these n dimensional areas and
it's all very fast and if you need more
sophisticated
algorithms and more like specific
algorithms then there is an extension to
num high potts I pi and scifi has things
like optimization algorithms numerical
integration solvers for adding value
problems sparse matrix representations
and so on so a pretty complete toolkit
for solving our kinds of problems and if
this is even not enough then sipho is
kind of a plugin interface which is
called side kids and their many cycles
for very specific purposes okay so
sometimes you can't you just can't avoid
to have these four loops and now the
question is how do we deal if we really
have to use for loops and this is was an
example from the Poisson equation it's
not really important to get the whole
formula here but one possibility to
solve poissons equation is by so-called
greens function and that and so we get
the solution by a sum of this greens
function expression here times the
right-hand side and the question is how
do we assemble the greens function G
this is obviously some kind of vector
and it has a pretty complex expression
so it would be very natural to just loop
over the indices here and then perform
these difficult computation and put it
into a vector and then we can use numpy
to deal with this vector and yeah
there's a nice library code number and
number has the ability to translate
simple Python functions to c code and do
a just-in-time compilation and call this
the c function so we can just create a
function which I called loop here which
performs a simple loop and then does
some complicated computations here I I
kept in the the simple times to
computation in order to do performance
measurements but
this part you could also do numerical
integration or some very complicated
stuff and yeah let's look again at the
performance so are there is another
library called Hope which does
essentially the same thing which is
pretty new and yeah as you can see using
the just-in-time compiler of number
gives us if four times slower execution
time then and see that's not too bad
because we come from a factor of 70 and
ours only factor of four or so and hope
is even faster than C and I have no clue
why I think maybe they do some parallel
computations them but hope seems to be
really good for at least four simple for
simple stuff em so lesson learned here
is if you can't avoid for loops and you
want to stay in the Python world and use
simple Python syntax you can try to use
number or hope in order to speed things
up yes I read about that I never tried
it i guess that i use number and hope
because its deadly simple you just have
to write this was it called decorator
jit and this is just a plain partner I
guess that pie pie is syntax is a bit
more complex but I'm not sure okay so
then maybe I tried it okay
for the levers that you yeah yeah but
you use oh yeah actually it has to
translate this somehow and it has to do
complicated stuff like guessing types
and so on and then yes it generates C
code and compile it just into end and
cords at Justin time and the compile
thing is cached so if you run the same
program twice it's pretty fast okay more
questions on that topic and I proceed
then if this is even not enough you can
always go for you native implementation
so you write your own C code and try to
like make a call a bill from the patent
side and the yeah the the easiest no
it's not the easiest thing but the most
natural way would be to use directly the
Python capi advantages are that you
don't need any additional libraries and
you have very fine-grained control over
what you're doing the downside is that
its I guess pretty complicated and you
have to write lots of boilerplate code
as I have read I actually never tried
this myself then another possibility is
to use swig swig is we can actually turn
the complete C++ library into a Python
library with exactly the same API and
you only have to give some hints to swig
how the types are connected to each
other and so on them but sometimes it's
a bit tricky to get the right type
conversions so another advantage of
speak would be that it supports more
than Python so it you can also create
Ruby bindings as far as I know and some
other languages and then the third thing
I wrote down but another actually it has
it myself but I wrote it down because
recently in the scientific community a
scientific computing community many
people starting to use siphon and as far
as i understand you kind of write your
seat extension with a specialist items
in doug's and you can also link see
libraries and so this seems to be the
then cool stuff right now as far as i
know and there are more possibilities so
they're actually yeah many ways to get
your c code run in patent em okay this
is just a small advertisement a slide so
we have a finite-difference code which
runs on CP 0 and GPO and users Nvidia
CUDA for the GPO computations and also
has numpy headers and an incomplete
Python interface and this can be found
here and now for the last section of my
talk I want to give a very brief
introduction into finite elements again
consider the Poisson equation which
looks like this and in finite elements
the discretization is not done by
discretizing the differential operator
but by discretizing the function space
and we have to start turning the
original problem into a variational
problem I just give a very brief
overview so we start integrating over
the equation and multiplying by
so-called test functions then we have to
transform the problem by integration by
parts so that we avoid second
derivatives this is done here and then
the right hand side is also just
integrated multiplied but test functions
and then as I said we discretize the
function space that that means we take
our mesh as a like construction rule for
our discrete function space and
hmm so every node belongs to one degree
of freedom of this new function space
and what if we do all the stuff we end
up with a simple linear system of
equations so we have the matrix times a
vector which is our solution equals some
right-hand side vector and obviously
this is a bit more complex than define a
different part and the challenging task
is to transform these integrals into
matrix entries and vector entries and
yes we use this project m this is a
finite element to with box for Python so
to say and it has a very easy
domain-specific language for the
description of these variational
problems so essentially you can see here
maybe I skipping so this integral
becomes somehow the matrix and in this
integral we have gradient you x gradient
V and then integrate over whole space
and as you can see the Fannie's guys
managed to come up with the
domain-specific language that really
looks like the mathematical problem so
we have the inner product of gradient
you x gradient vide x an integration
measure and what happens under the hood
is very complicated and takes this
just-in-time compilation approach one
step further because this code is
actually translated others as shown on
the next slide these form language as
they call it is actually transformed by
so called form compiler to see code so
there is a code generator that produces
optimized C code for the assembly of the
matrices and vectors and then this C
comp code complies to a certain
interface and then another component of
this library is able to use this
assembly code in order to really
assemble the matrices and vectors and
then there are like at
chapters for different linear algebra
backends so we can also switch between
the most popular in your add rebar
break-ins to sort of the whole system
and this is just yeah this is some of
the code that is generated by Phoenix so
we start with the definition of this
bilinear form this gradient you x
gradient v decorated by DX and what the
form compiler does is it produces
actually a lot of functions that are
able to compute different things but
this one is the central one because it's
responsible for computing the matrix
entries and as you can see there yeah
the code is even pretty beautiful and
it's really fast if it's compiled and
yeah that's currently like our main
focus to develop finite element software
and this is another advertisement slide
so we also have a finite element code
which is open source and which can be
found here in which heavily relies on
the Phoenix library and again almost
every scientific library you will find
will have some kind of numpy bindings if
it has python bindings it also has numpy
bindings and this is very handy because
in the case of Phoenix we can use the
number i interfaced to interface with
other libraries for example we don't
only use the finite element method but
also the boundary element method and
there is another library that also has
numpy bindings and so we can just use
numpy to exchange data between the
different libraries okay and with that I
want to conclude so yeah we chose python
s language because of its conscience and
very readable syntax I showed you that
pure python code for example for loops
might have performance issues and it's
best to use numpy for these kinds of
problems and like try to always go for
collective operators that yeah so you
avoid for loops
shows you that if you can't avoid four
loops their tools where you can stay in
the Python world but get more or less
the performance of C and I showed you
some possibilities how to like get your
C code run in Python and ya then many
scientific libraries have some kind of
numpy support so this is really kind of
a standard nowadays and this is our home
page where you can find the software we
are writing and some other stuff thank
you it's your trick of research in this
fight like this modulation methods or is
it just necessary evil for soldier
mm-hmm I have is it i think its smallest
a second but yeah you mean as an
alternative to numerical methods for the
solution of the PDE s yeah but actually
the PID is PPD is beer solving there
there are not solvable with analytical
tools so you have to go for the
numerical approach okay i know of some
aya i know that they're guys who use the
symbolic mathematics for example to
compute the matrix entries of these
finite element matrices because there
you have you have to perform integration
on triangles and you have pretty simple
functions some linear functions or
corporate quadratic functions and
sometimes there are analytic expressions
and these libraries are able to compute
them but usually this is done with
quadrature rules so everything is
approximated
wrong question also known as direction
I've learned also from piano that there
exists an automatic differentiation and
but i do not know if it is implied or
tickler for electromagnetics so that's
something in between civil infants yeah
mm-hmm so I think that automatic
differentiation doesn't really help to
solve partial differential equations
however there are special problems we
are looking at where you have for
example you you might have been a pretty
complicated expression for the
computation of the energy of the system
which depends on the magnetization
obviously in this case and then it might
be yeah you can use an automatic
differentiation in order to derive this
by the magnetization which you might be
not able to do with paper and pen
because it's really long formula and
this is has some value because the this
can be used in order to construct
minimization algorithms for example for
there but actually i'm not an expert in
this automatic differentiation topic so
i don't even know of this yeah so I
think I'm special is also the
disposition right and so what is then
can you change user action firms
possible exam more that's just dedicated
em so this might know F year by now is a
pure magnetic library but like if you
say you want to solve the Maxwell
equations or so then you could I guess
directly use this Phoenix library if you
yeah you have to convert them into
variational formulations and so on so
the code I road is pure magnetic
stuff but this Phoenix library is pretty
high level and you kept with only a few
lines of code you can solve a lot of
partial differential equations this is
anything has resulted in OT still if you
move your problem are you just B's and
and so on yeah Mike ok so i guess they
so we have to look at the very micro
structure in order to resolve the
exchange for you correctly and the
problem with the mighty scary thing is
that if we only if it was only for the
exchange interaction we could parallel
paralyze the code pretty well because
then you only have next neighbor
interactions and you can just divide
your measure into chunks and like
computer every chunk on a different core
and then you only have to take care of
the interfaces between chunks so the
problem of the multiscale problem is
that by the demagnetization field every
node is coupled to every node so we do
take care of it by trying to find fast
algorithms but you always have to
resolve this that every node is so there
are three codes and there are many
different possibilities to try to get
this fast but the main problem is of
this moody scale issue is that
paralyzation is difficult because every
node has capital every node message was
largely vendor is wrong skill we're okay
so yeah so usually you have to choose
the mesh size to be that there's a rule
of thumb there is something called the
exchange length that somehow gives a
measure on how on which scale this
exchange interaction takes place and
usually you have to mm use mesh sizes
below that in order to get meaningful
results
another possibility is to use theirs
there's work done on using other models
which may use caza measures where you
don't resolve the exchange interaction
but go for macroscopic Maxwell equations
then you are allowed to take but this is
yeah it's another one about the meshing
matching your message on machine there
are many tools so we don't write our own
mashing tools actually if you have
complicated geometries meshing is really
like a signs of its own and in fact yeah
it's not you don't you don't only need a
fine enough match but also things like
very steep angles are bad for the
methods because you get you get matrices
that are close to singular and so on so
measuring is a big issue we just use
software who does it for us no not at
all no we have other tools and they just
write out some files and then we can
read in the Phi's with our Python to
it's so the meshing is not done in
Python I mean if you if say you have a
you could have a body with different
materials right and then each material
would have another exchange length so
you could you could have caused our
measures in one part and final measures
on the other part and also maybe there
is a region of interest where you really
want to do things right and then you
will choose your match be very fine at
that particular region
you
you